you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now sounds
like a lot of fun but right now we got
to concentrate on the wind that is
whipping in other parts of the county
it's Breezy here 20 to 25 mile an hour
winds great view from our camera on top
of the Bank of America building from the
blaskey family companies it's over at
Rainbow and the 95 looking out to the
east there's the fabulous Las Vegas
strip and the Strat a thin layer of high
clouds way off in the distance otherwise
nothing but blue sky and 56 is the
official temperature out at Reed but we
always like to check into your
neighborhoods hanging on to the upper
40s in Mountains Edge in Rhodes ranch
close to 60 up at the Air Force Base
everybody else somewhere in the low to
the mid 50s and again those winds
gusting upwards of 15 to 25 miles an
hour much stronger as you get to the
Colorado River and then further south
into Laughlin and Prim meantime speaking
of Laughlin how about 59 there at 10
Death Valley at 69 over the Huffman prop
here at 52. you know what it got down to
10 degrees this morning in Ely you're a
few degrees above normal just barely
above normal in Cedar City right now mid
40's for Caliente 54 for Mesquite now we
topped it out at 58 at Reed
International yesterday we're going for
60 today don't forget the sun's going to
bed at about just after 4 30. check this
out got down to 39 at read some
neighborhoods were even cooler than that
so here's the next system where we're
talking about more wind coming in for
the weekend and we got this sort of like
a mini Nor'easter going on with rain
mixed with snow from Pennsylvania
heading on up into New York but back to
your most accurate eight day forecast
windy today we're going to be topping it
out at 60 the next several days wind
again Friday Saturday where high
temperatures will dip back into the
upper 50's overnight lows in the 30s so
Heather we just got to bundle up
especially in the morning hours yeah the
morning hours are super cold all right